programming throwdown episode 73 parallel computing with incredibuild take it away jason hey everyone so um chances are you're you're listening to this after the giveaway um we're recording this before the giveaway just before the giveaway but hopefully uh if you're a patreon subscriber you got one of our really cool uh um you know laser cut it laser cut acrylic little stencils uh that's a guarantee and hopefully if you're out there you got something else cool too in the raffle but today we have a really cool episode um we're gonna talk to dory exterman who's the cto of incredibuild and we're gonna talk all about kind of parallel computing um at incredibuild they've built this really cool system for
Programming Throwdown 第73期：Incredibuild 与并行计算，Jason 请开始你的表演。嘿，大家好，你们听到这期节目时，赠品活动应该已经结束了。我们是在活动开始前录制的，但希望如果你是 Patreon 的订阅者，已经收到了我们那款非常酷的激光切割亚克力小模板，那是保证有的。也希望如果你参与了抽奖，还能得到其他好东西。今天我们有一期非常棒的节目，我们将采访 Incredibuild 的首席技术官 Dory Exterman，聊聊并行计算。Incredibuild 构建了一个非常酷的系统，用于
um kind of combining. I'll let him kind of explain in more detail, but combining parallel computing and allowing you to use kind of the machines you have right now sitting around your office in like a distributed fashion. So, Dory, why don't you tell us kind of your background? What got you into parallel computing and sort of bit of history? So my background is I think I have more than 25 years of experience in software development. I did a lot of development in the areas of information and later on in low level as well and after that for a couple of years I consulted many companies in different areas of technologies advanced
嗯，某种程度上的整合。我会让他详细解释，但简单来说，就是结合并行计算，让你能够以分布式的方式利用办公室里现有的机器。所以，Dory，能介绍一下你的背景吗？是什么让你进入并行计算领域的？还有一些相关的历史。我的背景是，我想我有超过 25 年的软件开发经验。我做了很多信息领域的开发，后来也涉及底层开发。在那之后，我有几年时间为不同技术领域的许多公司提供咨询，包括先进的
technologies client server multi-tenant etc which led me quite naturally to part of computing and efficiency and optimization areas and seven years ago I joined in Credbill to lead the technical side of the company and since then I'm here and it's one of the coolest companies I ever worked in and I think I'm going to be here for a while so yeah. Cool, you've been there seven years right? Yeah, yeah, that's pretty amazing. Yeah, that's awesome. Was it, did you start the company or had it already been started?
技术、客户端服务器、多租户等等，这很自然地引导我进入了并行计算、效率和优化领域。七年前，我加入了 Incredibuild 负责公司的技术方面，从那以后我就一直在这里。这是我工作过的最酷的公司之一，我想我会在这里待上一段时间，所以，是的。太棒了，你在那儿待了七年，对吧？是的，是的，这很了不起。是的，太棒了。是你创立了这家公司，还是它已经成立了？
The company is very mature, it's, I think we are more than 15 years in the market already. Since, from the era in which power computing wasn't that popular, you only had one core on each PC. And then, you know, things went very slowly. So in these eras, when you needed more horsepower, you didn't have any way actually to achieve it. You couldn't buy, purchase a machine with multiple cores unless you had a lot of money. And the idea behind the company came actually from CETI at home, which is a NASA project from the beginning that tried to
这家公司非常成熟，我想我们已经在市场上存在超过 15 年了。从那个并行计算还不那么流行的时代开始，当时每台电脑只有一个核心。然后，你知道，事情进展非常缓慢。所以在那个时代，当你需要更多算力时，你实际上没有任何办法实现。除非你有很多钱，否则你买不到多核机器。这家公司背后的想法实际上来自 NASA 的一个早期项目 SETI@home，它试图
find extraterrestrial lives using distributed computing. So in the 80s you were able to install some software on your computer and then NASA would distribute these audio files they recorded and your computer was able to analyze these audio files and see if there are signs for extraterrestrial lives. I remember that. Yeah, I remember having the SETI at home screensaver and so basically when your computer went idle, instead of having a bouncing ball or something like that, you would just be scanning for anything.
通过分布式计算寻找外星生命。所以在 80 年代，你可以在电脑上安装一些软件，然后 NASA 会分发他们录制的音频文件，你的电脑就能分析这些文件，看看是否有外星生命的迹象。我记得那个。是的，我记得我有 SETI@home 的屏幕保护程序，基本上当你的电脑闲置时，它不会显示弹跳球之类的东西，而是会扫描任何信号。
And it's still a live project, I think. They're still doing that. And in this era when you had just very limited resources, so NASA really needed your own computers in order to scale this. And the founders of the Incredibles thought, well, if NASA is doing this for extraterrestrial life finding, why can't we do that for other stuff as well? And they started in accelerating visual studio builds.
我想这仍然是一个活跃的项目。他们还在做这件事。在那个资源非常有限的时代，NASA 确实需要你的电脑来扩展规模。Incredibuild 的创始人们想，好吧，如果 NASA 能为了寻找外星生命这样做，为什么我们不能把这用在其他事情上呢？于是他们从加速 Visual Studio 构建开始了。
So this was 15 years ago, when you only had one core. And when I joined the company, we already had multiple cores. So we thought that once people would have 16 cores or even four cores, the problem would go away. But in fact, what we are always finding is that in the same ratio as the amount of cores are raising in your local machine, the problem grows bigger as well. So people always need more resources, which makes us still relevant and even more relevant than we were in the past. Cool, that makes sense.
那是 15 年前，当时你只有一个核心。当我加入公司时，我们已经有了多核。所以我们认为，一旦人们有了 16 核甚至 4 核，这个问题就会消失。但事实上，我们总是发现，随着本地机器核心数量的增加，问题也在按比例扩大。所以人们总是需要更多的资源，这使得我们依然具有相关性，甚至比过去更重要。酷，这很有道理。
Yeah, I mean, I think you kind of touched on it, but yeah, it sounds like the big motivation behind parallel computing is that you have sort of some very expensive process but it can be broken up into pieces and then solved in parallel yeah um what what are uh you what are you most of your customers what what are they you know trying to solve i mean not you know i'm sure there's there's you know confidential things and things like that. But in general, what's the sort of areas that your company can help? Essentially, we've started with accelerating Visual Studio. So we are focused there even today.
是的，我的意思是，我想你已经触及到了这一点，但听起来并行计算背后的巨大动力是，你有一些非常昂贵的流程，但它可以被拆分成碎片，然后并行解决。是的，嗯，你们的大多数客户，他们在试图解决什么问题？我的意思是，我确定有一些保密的事情之类的。但总的来说，你们公司能在哪些领域提供帮助？本质上，我们是从加速 Visual Studio 开始的。所以即使在今天，我们仍然专注于此。
So many of our customers, I wouldn't say all, but many of our customers, I wouldn't say all, but many of our customers are Visual Studio users and are accelerating either their Visual Studio compilations or any kind of computation that they have as part of their continuous integration systems. Six, five years ago, we opened the technology. We wrote it from the beginning to be generic. And we opened the technology for users to be able to use it for any kind of compute-intense execution. So today, users are using it for compilation, for testing, packaging, artificial intelligence training, weather forecasting, financial derivatives. We are highly popular in the gaming industry. In the gaming industry, I think we are used by something like the largest 1,000 studios in the world doing Xbox, Sony, Nvidia Shield, Nintendo, PC, and Android, and VR, and any kind of game.
所以我们的许多客户，我不会说全部，但许多客户是 Visual Studio 用户，他们正在加速他们的 Visual Studio 编译，或者作为持续集成系统一部分的任何计算。五六年前，我们开放了这项技术。我们从头开始编写它，使其具有通用性。我们开放了这项技术，让用户能够将其用于任何类型的计算密集型执行。所以今天，用户将其用于编译、测试、打包、人工智能训练、天气预报、金融衍生品。我们在游戏行业非常受欢迎。在游戏行业，我想我们被全球大约 1000 家最大的工作室使用，用于 Xbox、Sony、Nvidia Shield、Nintendo、PC、Android 和 VR，以及任何类型的游戏。
And the reason that it's highly popular in the gaming industry, I believe, is that they have so many things that they do as part of game development that require a lot of resources that are compute-intensive. So it's not only C++ compilation, but usually it's rendering, video rendering, image processing. You have a lot of shaders, which, for example, when you have a physics engine, you need to pre-calculate the shades of the objects in order for you not to do that while the game is running.
我相信它在游戏行业如此受欢迎的原因是，作为游戏开发的一部分，他们做了太多需要大量资源且计算密集的事情。所以不仅仅是 C++ 编译，通常还有渲染、视频渲染、图像处理。你有很多着色器，例如，当你有一个物理引擎时，你需要预先计算物体的阴影，这样你就不用在游戏运行时做这些了。
Yeah, this is something not a lot of people know but basically the game uh developers they they try to sort of cheat as much as possible like yeah if there's sort of really nice soft lighting chances are that that's not being computed on the fly because that's extremely extremely expensive um there's this thing called monte car, you know, photon mapping, where literally each light just emits a bunch of rays of energy. And every time one of those rays of energy hits anything, it bounces and it becomes basically a new light source. And so it just blows up exponentially. Right. And that's how, you know, you could imagine even in real life, if you open up a window just a tiny amount, you can light up a whole room. And that's because the photons are bouncing all over the place. Right.
是的，这是很多人不知道的事情，但基本上游戏开发者他们试图尽可能多地“作弊”，就像，如果有一种非常好的柔和光照，很有可能它不是实时计算的，因为那极其极其昂贵。有一种东西叫蒙特卡洛，你知道，光子映射，字面上每个光源只是发射一堆能量射线。每当其中一条能量射线击中任何东西时，它就会反弹，基本上变成一个新的光源。所以它呈指数级爆炸。没错。你可以想象，即使在现实生活中，如果你把窗户打开一点点，你就能照亮整个房间。这是因为光子在到处反弹。没错。
And so to to make that same effect in the game where it's not like everything is pitch black except for where the sun hits, they need to do this really, really expensive process. And so that always happens, you know before uh the game is even shipped they just pre-compute that um for everything that that isn't moving and as you said yeah it's extremely expensive but it's completely parallelizable you could do every room independently yeah and also for example if you take uh the fifa game for example you have different kind of stadium different different kind of lighting. And this lighting affects the way that lights and shades are going to interact. And also the players themselves.
所以为了在游戏中实现同样的效果，而不是除了太阳照射的地方外一切漆黑，他们需要进行这个非常非常昂贵的处理。所以这总是发生在游戏发布之前，他们只是为所有不移动的东西预先计算这些。正如你所说，是的，它极其昂贵，但它是完全可并行化的，你可以独立处理每个房间。是的，而且例如，如果你以 FIFA 游戏为例，你有不同类型的体育场，不同类型的光照。这种光照会影响光线和阴影相互作用的方式。还有球员本身。
For example, Messi and Ibrahimovic have different sizes and different way of interacting with the light. So you can pre-compute that. And that's what they're doing. And they have millions of pre-computations, and they can prepare that in advance, and that's what they're doing, and they're doing it with IncrediBuild. Cool, that makes sense. So what are the big differences between, you know, for example, instead of IncrediBuild, I could go and get some really powerhouse machine.
例如，梅西和伊布拉希莫维奇有不同的体型和与光线相互作用的方式。所以你可以预先计算这些。这就是他们正在做的。他们有数百万次的预计算，他们可以提前准备好，这就是他们正在做的，他们正在用 Incredibuild 来做。酷，这很有道理。那么，例如，除了 Incredibuild，我还可以去买一些非常强大的机器，这两者之间有什么大区别？
Maybe it has two processors. Maybe it has 36 cores or something like that. I don't know if that's even supported. Let's say 36 cores exist. No, you can say 80. Oh, okay. Oh, we have customers with 80 cores, yeah. And so what's the difference between me doing that,
也许它有两个处理器。也许它有 36 个核心之类的。我不知道这是否被支持。假设 36 核存在。不，你可以说 80。哦，好的。哦，我们有拥有 80 核的客户，是的。那么，我这样做有什么区别，
spending maybe a lot of money up front and buying some 80-core machine versus using something like IncrediBuild doing that, spending maybe a lot of money up front and buying some 80 core machine versus using something like Incredibuild that's going to go back and forth over the network. So I'll give you a live scenario. For example, let's assume you are a very large, I don't want to name names, but let's assume you're a very large company, an enterprise company, and you're working on a game or a different project software, and you have 100 engineers working on this software.
预先花很多钱买一台 80 核的机器，与使用像 Incredibuild 这样通过网络来回传输数据的工具相比，有什么区别？所以我给你一个真实场景。例如，假设你是一家非常大的公司，我不想点名，但假设你是一家非常大的企业公司，你正在开发一款游戏或其他项目软件，你有 100 名工程师在开发这个软件。
So you'll need to purchase 100 multiplied by 80 core machine in order for each engineer to have these 80 cores to really run faster. With IncrediBuild, you can have each developer having eight cores on his machine and each of them will be able to use all the IOS CPU cycles with IncrediBuild seamlessly of all the other engineers working in his local network. So every engineer can essentially tap with IncrediBuild into 800 cores instead of just 80, which will also cost you much less. An 80-core machine is very expensive.
所以你需要购买 100 台 80 核的机器，才能让每位工程师拥有这 80 个核心来真正加快运行速度。使用 Incredibuild，你可以让每位开发人员在自己的机器上拥有 8 个核心，并且他们每个人都能通过 Incredibuild 无缝地利用本地网络中所有其他工程师机器上的所有空闲 CPU 周期。所以每位工程师本质上都可以通过 Incredibuild 调用 800 个核心，而不是仅仅 80 个，这也会让你花费少得多。一台 80 核的机器非常昂贵。
You won't be able to purchase one for each of your developers. And also, 80-core, you think it's huge, but when you have a computation that takes 24 hours, that takes two days, even 80 cores is not fast enough. Our users are using CrediBuild to distribute to hundreds of ports, and not only 84. 84 is not
你不可能为你的每位开发人员购买一台。而且，80 核，你觉得它很大，但当你有一个需要 24 小时、需要两天时间的计算时，即使是 80 核也不够快。我们的用户正在使用 Incredibuild 分布到数百个端口，而不仅仅是 80 个。80 个不是
the high end of our users. That makes sense. Also, Bill goes on vacation to the Canary Islands or something. His machine is just sitting there wasted if he didn't have some type of distributed. With Intranet you have other stuff as well. So for example, we have
我们用户的高端水平。这很有道理。另外，如果 Bill 去加那利群岛度假之类的，如果他没有某种分布式系统，他的机器就闲置浪费了。有了 Incredibuild，你还有其他东西。例如，我们有
companies that have multiple sites, geographical sites. So one site, when in one site it's daylight and working hours, the other site it's nighttime and their resources are idle. So they can use the resources from one site to accelerate the computation of the other sites, which is quite cool. Another thing is that you can always
拥有多个站点的公司，地理位置上的站点。所以一个站点，当一个站点是白天和工作时间时，另一个站点是夜间，他们的资源是空闲的。所以他们可以使用来自一个站点的资源来加速另一个站点的计算，这非常酷。另一件事是，你总是可以
with IncrediBit, and that's not something you can do when you purchase hardware, and this is something we see more and more. You can always scale to the public cloud. Essentially all we need is a virtual machine. So especially in peak times, before game release, before Christmas, when you need to do more testing, you have more compilation.
使用 Incredibuild，这是你购买硬件时做不到的，这是我们看到越来越多的情况。你总是可以扩展到公有云。本质上我们只需要一台虚拟机。所以特别是在高峰期，游戏发布前，圣诞节前，当你需要做更多测试时，你有更多的编译。
And before releases, that's usually when you need more resources and you don't have them. With IncrediVity, you can always scale. You can say, okay, I'll just add some 100 cores in any kind of public cloud available and connect them to my local network, and boom,
在发布之前，通常是你需要更多资源而你却没有的时候。有了 Incredibuild，你总是可以扩展。你可以说，好吧，我只是在任何可用的公有云中添加 100 个核心，并将它们连接到我的本地网络，然后，砰，
you have more resources to use. And, you know, time to market is very essential in these sectors. That makes sense. I guess, you know, what if, you know, what if you have a problem where there's sort of a lot of data? You know, so is that sort of, is that something that IncrediBuild can handle? Or how would you go about solving that problem? Like, for example, I mean,
你有更多的资源可以使用。而且，你知道，上市时间在这些行业非常重要。这很有道理。我想，你知道，如果，你知道，如果你有一个有很多数据的问题怎么办？你知道，所以这是 Incredibuild 能处理的事情吗？或者你会如何解决这个问题？例如，我的意思是，
you brought the example of the arenas, the football arenas. I mean, maybe those files aren't that large and they can get passed around. It's really the computation. But what if it's something like... Yeah, gigs of data, that's right. That's a problem. So there are large meshes. There are... That's usually specific. So there are large meshes. That's usually in specific types of software.
你举了足球场的例子。我的意思是，也许那些文件不是那么大，它们可以被传递。真正的问题是计算。但如果它是像……是的，几 GB 的数据，没错。那是个问题。所以有大的网格。有……这通常是特定的。所以有大的网格。这通常在特定类型的软件中。
For example, in genetic algorithms, when you're trying to calculate genetic algorithm stuff, usually the data is very, very large. If you can break the data into multiple subsets, then it will work for you. It will be good because you can say, okay, when I'm running these types of algorithms, I need only this subset of the data,
例如，在遗传算法中，当你试图计算遗传算法的东西时，通常数据非常非常大。如果你能把数据分成多个子集，那么它对你来说就会有效。这很好，因为你可以说，好吧，当我运行这些类型的算法时，我只需要这个数据子集，
and then you can pass it away, which is cool. But there are scenarios in which you have really, really huge data, and not only that you have huge data, you need to load all this data to your memory, or else the computation time will be very, very large. In these kind of very specific types of calculation, usually you won't be able to get around it, nothing will help you, not an incredible, not a cluster, and you need a supercomputer in order to compute that in an efficient manner.
然后你可以把它传走，这很酷。但有些场景中，你有非常非常巨大的数据，不仅你有巨大的数据，你还需要把所有这些数据加载到你的内存中，否则计算时间会非常非常长。在这些非常特定类型的计算中，通常你无法绕过它，什么都帮不了你，不是 Incredibuild，也不是集群，你需要一台超级计算机才能以有效的方式计算它。
So there are specific problems that you'll need an HPC machine, and that's why HPC machine exists. But if you can break the data into multiple and smaller data sets along with the computation that go around that, then you can use IncrediBuild or you can use clusters or any kind of distributed computing technology. So I guess what's the difference then between, you know, I've seen there's, let's say, OpenMP or MPI or these kind of things. Or I guess maybe OpenMP is a good example where you, you know, or maybe LaPack or something where there's parallelism kind of built frameworks where sort of every machine is running some dedicated kind of server that can handle chunks of data and processes. It sounds like IncrediBuild kind of fits in between. It's sort of for people who don't want
所以有些特定的问题你需要一台 HPC 机器，这就是为什么 HPC 机器存在的原因。但如果你能把数据分成多个较小的数据集，并配合围绕它们的计算，那么你就可以使用 Incredibuild，或者你可以使用集群或任何类型的分布式计算技术。所以我猜，那么，我看到有 OpenMP 或 MPI 或这类东西，它们之间有什么区别？或者我猜也许 OpenMP 是一个很好的例子，你，你知道，或者也许是 LaPack 之类的，那里有内置的并行框架，每台机器都在运行某种专用的服务器，可以处理数据块和进程。听起来 Incredibuild 介于两者之间。它适合那些不想
to have this huge farm of machines just sitting there to do computation and have to deal with map reduce and all of that um but it's also not all the way on the other end where you're having to write like modify a lot of c++ code this is kind of right in the middle so i think that uh the major difference so hadoop is usually usually for data analysis and it's less used for computation. But although it is, the main purpose of Hadoop is usually for big data analytics and things like that. And with both in Hadoop and OpenMP or other infrastructure for parallel computing, you'll need to write your software in order to accommodate these technologies,
拥有这个巨大的机器农场只是为了做计算，并且不得不处理 MapReduce 和所有这些东西的人，但它也不完全在另一端，你必须编写或修改大量的 C++ 代码。这就在中间。所以我认为，主要的区别在于：Hadoop 通常用于数据分析，较少用于计算。虽然确实如此，但 Hadoop 的主要目的通常是大数据分析之类的事情。而在 Hadoop 和 OpenMP 或其他并行计算基础设施中，你需要编写你的软件以适应这些技术，
these infrastructures. You need to deeply integrate with these technologies and you need to write your software in advance in order for it to be able to work with these kind of technologies. You need to consider a lot of stuff. You need to consider how you handle fault tolerance or if a node just goes down, what is the computer doing in your software, how you handle scheduling, how you handle in advance,
这些基础设施。你需要与这些技术深度集成，并且你需要提前编写你的软件，以便它能够与这些类型的技术一起工作。你需要考虑很多事情。你需要考虑如何处理容错，或者如果一个节点宕机了，你的软件中的计算在做什么，你如何处理调度，你如何提前处理，
how you handle the data transfer and synchronization. With IncrediBuild, the idea behind the product was to give you a solution that will simply work out of the box. So, for example, if you have something that you wrote, okay, and if I provide you, so you wrote and you can run eight processes, hundreds of processes in Parallel, but you only have eight cores. With IncrediBuild, the idea was that you just plug in IncrediBuild, you install it on every agent you have in your local network, and IncrediBuild will seamlessly use these idle resources of the other machines as though they reside in your own laptop. You don't need to install anything on this remote machine besides IncrediBuild.
你如何处理数据传输和同步。使用 Incredibuild，产品背后的想法是为你提供一个开箱即用的解决方案。所以，例如，如果你写了一些东西，好的，如果你提供给我，所以你写了，你可以并行运行 8 个进程、数百个进程，但你只有 8 个核心。使用 Incredibuild，想法是你只需插入 Incredibuild，将其安装在你本地网络中的每个代理上，Incredibuild 就会无缝地使用其他机器的这些空闲资源，就好像它们驻留在你自己的笔记本电脑上一样。除了 Incredibuild，你不需要在远程机器上安装任何东西。
You don't need to transfer files. That's kind of magic. We're doing it with a very unique technology which allows us to virtualize the process on the fly. But essentially, the idea was to give you a fly-and-play solution. So you don't need to write anything specific in your software in order to allow IncrediBuild to do its trick and allow you to scale. So I think that's the major difference between these kind of solutions. Cool. So how does that actually work? So in other words, let's say I have some program that,
你不需要传输文件。这有点像魔法。我们用一种非常独特的技术来做到这一点，它允许我们在运行中虚拟化进程。但本质上，这个想法是为你提供一个即插即用的解决方案。所以你不需要在你的软件中编写任何特定的东西来让 Incredibuild 发挥它的作用并让你扩展。所以我认为这是这些解决方案之间的主要区别。酷。那么它是如何工作的呢？所以换句话说，假设我有一个程序，
let's say it plays a game and it outputs the result of that. It plays a game between two AIs and it outputs the result of that game to a file. And you want to do that, let's say, a hundred times or a thousand times. So what you want in the end is to have, you know, a thousand files on your own machine with all of the replays.
假设它玩一个游戏并输出结果。它在两个 AI 之间玩一个游戏，并将该游戏的结果输出到一个文件。你想这样做，假设，一百次或一千次。所以你最终想要的是，你知道，在你自己的机器上有 1000 个文件，包含所有的回放。
And so if IncrediBuild is farming all of that out, how does it go and collect all the files and how does it sort of manage all of that? So I think that's the very unique technology we developed in IncrediBuild, which is a process-level virtualization technology, which allows us essentially to take any kind of process and distribute it to any kind of remote machine and emulate the environment that the process requires in order to successfully run on this remote machine as though the process is running
所以如果 Incredibuild 把所有这些都分发出去，它是如何去收集所有文件的，它是如何管理所有这些的？所以我认为这是我们在 Incredibuild 开发的非常独特的技术，这是一种进程级虚拟化技术，它本质上允许我们获取任何类型的进程并将其分发到任何类型的远程机器，并模拟该进程为了在远程机器上成功运行所需要的环境，就好像该进程正在
on your local computer. The way that we're doing that for any kind of process, it's not only the output file, because for example, so let's assume that as you said you have this game that you want to play 100, 1000 times. This game is a process that gets some parameters. With IncrediBuild, automatically you run all these processes in parallel. IncrediBuild, automatically you run all these processes in parallel. In CrediBuild, you simply have your command line. Let's assume that you have a power meter saying how many of these processes to run in parallel. So you will have playgames.exe 100, which will say playgames.exe to execute 100 game.exe.
你的本地计算机上运行一样。我们为任何类型的进程这样做的方式，不仅仅是输出文件，因为例如，所以让我们假设正如你所说，你有这个你想玩 100 次、1000 次的游戏。这个游戏是一个获取一些参数的进程。使用 Incredibuild，你自动并行运行所有这些进程。Incredibuild，你只需使用你的命令行。让我们假设你有一个参数，说明并行运行多少个这些进程。所以你会有 playgames.exe 100，它会说 playgames.exe 执行 100 个 game.exe。
In CrediBuild, your main process will run all these 100 game.exe. Incredibly, your main process will run all these 100 processes. Incredibly, it will then take hold of this queue of you trying to execute 100 processes, and it will interact with a coordinator component of Incredibly, telling you, listen, I need 100 cores. Just give me whatever you have. And let's assume that the coordinator looks around all the agents that are installed in your network and will be able to provide you 100 cores. And then the IncrediBit on your local machine will tell a remote machine to run an instance of a Game.exe. Now, on this remote machine,
在 Incredibuild 中，你的主进程将运行所有这 100 个 game.exe。Incredibuild 随后将接管你试图执行 100 个进程的队列，它将与 Incredibuild 的协调器组件交互，告诉你，听着，我需要 100 个核心。把你有的都给我。让我们假设协调器查看了安装在你网络中的所有代理，并将能够为你提供 100 个核心。然后你本地机器上的 Incredibuild 会告诉远程机器运行一个 Game.exe 的实例。现在，在这台远程机器上，
you don't have anything besides IncrediBit. You don't have the game.exe process. You don't have the DLLs that maybe the libraries that this exe requires. You don't have input files. Nothing is there besides IncrediBit. The way that we allow this to happen is on the remote machine, you have an IncrediBuild agent.
除了 Incredibuild，你什么都没有。你没有 game.exe 进程。你没有这个 exe 可能需要的 DLL 或库。你没有输入文件。除了 Incredibuild，那里什么都没有。我们允许这种情况发生的方式是，在远程机器上，你有一个 Incredibuild 代理。
And the IncrediBuild agent will run this process on the remote machine and will essentially inject IncrediBuild code into the process level. So this code of IncrediBuild, this is injection technologies, this code of IncrediBuild will actually act as a middleman between the process running remotely and the remote operating system. So all the calls that interest us, that tries to reach the operating system from your process, will first be intercepted by IncrediBuild. So once you try to open the file on a specific location,
Incredibuild 代理将在远程机器上运行此进程，并将本质上把 Incredibuild 代码注入到进程级别。所以这个 Incredibuild 的代码，这是注入技术，这个 Incredibuild 的代码实际上将充当远程运行的进程和远程操作系统之间的中间人。所以所有我们感兴趣的、试图从你的进程到达操作系统的调用，都将首先被 Incredibuild 拦截。所以一旦你试图在特定位置打开文件，
this file does not exist on the remote machine because you don't have anything, any DLL, any input file on the remote machine. But Incredibly will intercept the call. So if you try to open a file in my documents, a.txt, for example, Incredibly will intercept the call. It will see that you don't have the file, the Incredibly cache. It's kind of sandbox we manage on the remote machine. And it will see that you don't have the file in the Incredible cache, it's a kind of sandbox we manage on the remote machine, and it will then go to the Incredible agent on your local machine and ask for this file, and it will copy this file on demand to a special location, special cache that we have on the remote machine.
这个文件在远程机器上不存在，因为你没有任何 DLL，没有任何输入文件在远程机器上。但 Incredibuild 会拦截该调用。所以如果你试图打开我的文档中的一个文件，例如 a.txt，Incredibuild 会拦截该调用。它会看到你没有这个文件，Incredibuild 缓存。这是我们在远程机器上管理的一种沙箱。它会看到你没有这个文件在 Incredibuild 缓存中，这是我们在远程机器上管理的一种沙箱，然后它会去你本地机器上的 Incredibuild 代理并索要这个文件，它会按需将此文件复制到我们在远程机器上拥有的一个特殊位置、特殊缓存中。
And it will then redirect the API code, the OS API code, instead of opening the file in my documents in Windows, it will say open the file in C program files in credit build cache a.txt and then it will only then the API code will be passed to the operating system. The operating system will then go to the location we provided instead of the original location. The file exists there because we copied it, and it will open a file and bring back a handle. Incredible will then take this handle, and it will forward it to your process running on the remote machine. So from the OS perspective, there was a file, and it opened it. And from the process
然后它会重定向 API 调用，OS API 调用，而不是在 Windows 的我的文档中打开文件，它会说在 C 程序文件的 Incredibuild 缓存中打开 a.txt，然后只有这样 API 调用才会被传递给操作系统。操作系统随后会去我们提供的位置而不是原始位置。文件存在那里，因为我们复制了它，它会打开一个文件并带回一个句柄。Incredibuild 随后会获取这个句柄，并将其转发给你在远程机器上运行的进程。所以从 OS 的角度来看，有一个文件，它打开了它。从进程
running remotely, the process perspective, it has handled it and can work with. So this is what we're doing for any kind of file system related call or any kind of thing that we'd like to virtualize. So it can be opening and loading a DLL, writing a file, opening a file, creating a directory, accessing the registry. Every kind of thing is virtualized on the fly by IncrediGrid. So essentially the remote process thinks is actually it has on the fly providing with an emulation of everything that it needs as though it's being
远程运行的角度来看，进程的角度来看，它已经处理了它并且可以使用它。所以这就是我们为任何类型的文件系统相关调用或任何我们想要虚拟化的东西所做的。所以它可以是打开和加载 DLL、写入文件、打开文件、创建目录、访问注册表。每一件事都是由 Incredibuild 实时虚拟化的。所以本质上远程进程认为它实际上是在实时提供它需要的一切的模拟，就好像它正在
executed on the local machine. So once the file, once this process tries to write it out we do the same thing. We intercept the create file and write operation and we redirect them to our we do the same thing. We intercept the create file and write operation, and we redirect them to our own special location. And once the process finishes running, we simply synchronize back the files that were created by this process
在本地机器上执行一样。所以一旦文件，一旦这个进程试图写出它，我们就做同样的事情。我们拦截 create file 和 write 操作，并将它们重定向到我们自己的特殊位置。一旦进程运行结束，我们只需将此进程创建的文件同步回
to the original place where the process tried to write them on your local machine. So from your perspective as a user, it's really as though you have 100 cores running for you on your local device. And it's not only cores, it's also memory, it's also any kind of network bandwidth you can use more because you're actually using more computers, more memory, more cores, more CPU processing power, etc. That makes sense. So just to walk through the example here,
原始位置，即进程试图将其写入你本地机器上的位置。所以从你作为用户的角度来看，这真的就像你在本地设备上运行了 100 个核心一样。而且不仅仅是核心，还有内存，还有任何类型的网络带宽，你可以使用更多，因为你实际上是在使用更多的计算机、更多的内存、更多的核心、更多的 CPU 处理能力等。这很有道理。所以只是为了走一遍这里的例子，
so you would, let's say you had. So just to walk through the example here, so you would let's say you had 100 machines you called play game with 100 it would create 100 processes, let's say one on each machine, and then when it went to play the game, that game might require all sorts of rules
所以你会，假设你有。所以只是为了走一遍这里的例子，所以你会，假设你有 100 台机器，你调用 play game 100，它会创建 100 个进程，假设每台机器一个，然后当它去玩游戏时，那个游戏可能需要各种规则
and other files and on demand those get pulled from your machine and then distributed out, like fanned out to these 100 machines, they're going to go and play 100 games in the time it would take you to play one game on one thread locally. And then when the game finishes, they'll save the replay, and the Incredibuild will detect, oh, you know, there's a new file here that was created by this remote process.
和其他文件，按需从你的机器上拉取，然后分发出去，就像扇出到这 100 台机器一样，它们将去玩 100 场游戏，时间是你本地在一个线程上玩一场游戏的时间。然后当游戏结束时，它们会保存回放，Incredibuild 会检测到，哦，你知道，这里有一个由这个远程进程创建的新文件。
I better send it back to the main computer so that it knows it's there. Yeah, exactly. Simple, right? That makes sense. Yeah, I think it's clever. Yeah, very clever. But it requires a lot of deep understanding into the operating system, low level, intercepting all these calls and implementing this. It's highly complex. And you're speaking about multi-tenant, asynchronous, highly parallel execution that makes it very complex. Fault tolerant. If one machine goes down, we need to recover automatically.
我最好把它发回主计算机，这样它就知道它在那里了。是的，完全正确。很简单，对吧？这很有道理。是的，我认为这很聪明。是的，非常聪明。但这需要对操作系统、底层、拦截所有这些调用并实现这一点有非常深刻的理解。它非常复杂。而且你谈论的是多租户、异步、高度并行的执行，这使它非常复杂。容错。如果一台机器宕机了，我们需要自动恢复。
These are things when you're trying to do something like this yourself, you need to take care of that with Incredibilit taking care of it for you. So this is quite complex to develop. Yeah, that makes sense. Go ahead, Patrick. Yeah, so doing this process-level virtualization, does that imply that all of the machines are running a fairly similar version of the same operating system? So we support different flavors of the same. So if you are running Windows, you can work with any kind of Windows version.
当你试图自己做这样的事情时，你需要处理这些，而 Incredibuild 会为你处理它。所以开发这个非常复杂。是的，这很有道理。请继续，Patrick。是的，所以做这种进程级虚拟化，是否意味着所有的机器都在运行非常相似版本的相同操作系统？所以我们支持相同操作系统的不同版本。所以如果你运行的是 Windows，你可以使用任何类型的 Windows 版本。
You can distribute Windows 7 to Windows Service 2016. But you cannot distribute Windows to Linux because the way the operating system works are different. But in Linux, for example, you can work with Ubuntu, CentOS, Fedora, etc. in the same grid. So we can't distribute Ubuntu
你可以分发 Windows 7 到 Windows Server 2016。但你不能将 Windows 分发到 Linux，因为操作系统的工作方式不同。但在 Linux 中，例如，你可以在同一个网格中与 Ubuntu、CentOS、Fedora 等一起工作。所以我们不能分发 Ubuntu
processes to Fedora or to CentOS or etc. So then for things like shared libraries and dynamically loaded things, those all still have to be passed over the network then? Yeah, but we only need to pass them once and then we cache them on the remote machine. So the next time
进程到 Fedora 或 CentOS 等。那么对于共享库和动态加载的东西，那些仍然必须通过网络传递吗？是的，但我们只需要传递它们一次，然后我们将它们缓存在远程机器上。所以下一次
you run any process that will require the same libraries, they're already there on your helper machine so we don't need to transfer them back. So you only get this latency usually on the first process you ever execute on your infrastructure. Because in a regular scenario, your 100 developers will more or less use the same kind of DLLs, the same infrastructure.
你运行任何需要相同库的进程时，它们已经在你的辅助机器上了，所以我们不需要把它们传回来。所以你通常只在你在基础设施上执行的第一个进程上获得这种延迟。因为在常规场景中，你的 100 名开发人员或多或少会使用相同类型的 DLL，相同的基础设施。
So your helpers, after a while, their cache will be filled with data, and then their network latency will be very minimal. From our test, it's just a warm-up call, a few milliseconds. And then how do you sort of understand up front the weight of a process? So in Jason's example of playing 100 games, all 100 processes are doing roughly the same amount of work um but what happens if you know you're spanning up 100 and you have you know a exponential distribution where you have a few processes doing you know orders of magnitude more work but yet you know in your your you know sort of networked set of computers some are very powerful some are
所以你的辅助机器，过了一会儿，它们的缓存就会填满数据，然后它们的网络延迟就会非常小。根据我们的测试，这只是一个预热调用，几毫秒。那么你如何预先理解一个进程的权重呢？所以在 Jason 玩 100 场游戏的例子中，所有 100 个进程都在做大致相同的工作量，但如果，你知道，你启动了 100 个，并且你有一个指数分布，你有几个进程做了几个数量级更多的工作，但然而，你知道，在你的联网计算机集中，有些非常强大，有些
not yeah so uh we have we have so we have a component which we call a coordinator. Its role is to do assignment algorithms. So all the agents, all the incredible agents report to this coordinator, and the only job the coordinator needs to do is to coordinate between these agents. So the way that we solve this question that you have is by providing each agent some kind of grade. We grade each agent, each computer, and then we will always try to use the, you know, the strongest machines at the beginning and not the weak machines. And we have some optimizations for
不是，那怎么办？是的，所以我们有一个我们称之为协调器的组件。它的作用是做分配算法。所以所有的代理，所有的 Incredibuild 代理都向这个协调器报告，协调器唯一需要做的工作就是在这些代理之间进行协调。所以我们解决你这个问题的办法是给每个代理某种等级。我们给每个代理、每台计算机打分，然后我们总是会尝试在开始时使用，你知道，最强的机器，而不是弱的机器。我们有一些优化
that. And for example some optimizations for that. And for example, let's give another example. For example, let's assume that I'm using your machine as a helper. Your machine was idle, so I used your machine. But then you as a developer, suddenly you do something on your machine. You copy a large amount of data or you just start running a game. We don't want to disturb you so once you started the game and you want to play it and Incredibility is utilizing your idle resources these resources are not idle anymore so one of the mechanism is to be able to detect this and to stop all the
针对这一点。例如，让我们再举一个例子。例如，假设我正在使用你的机器作为辅助机器。你的机器是空闲的，所以我使用了你的机器。但随后你作为开发人员，突然你在你的机器上做了一些事情。你复制了大量数据，或者你只是开始玩游戏。我们不想打扰你，所以一旦你开始玩游戏，你想玩它，而 Incredibuild 正在利用你的空闲资源，这些资源不再是空闲的了，所以机制之一是能够检测到这一点并停止所有
Incredibility processes running on your machine as a helper in order not to disturb you doing your own work and re-executing them on a different machine. So from my perspective as a user, I won't even know that my processes were terminated on your machine and were rescheduled to run on a different machine. So there are a lot of things we need to take into consideration in order to streamline the experience. What about inter-process communication? How does that work? So that's a good question. With IncrediBuild
在你的机器上作为辅助机器运行的 Incredibuild 进程，为了不打扰你做你自己的工作，并在另一台机器上重新执行它们。所以从我作为用户的角度来看，我甚至不知道我的进程在你的机器上被终止了，并被重新调度到另一台机器上运行。所以为了简化体验，我们需要考虑很多事情。进程间通信呢？它是如何工作的？这是一个好问题。使用 Incredibuild
there are a set of limitations that you need to meet in order to be able to use our product. So inter-process communication is one of them but it really depends on the way you do inter-process communication. If you're using, for example, shared memory in order to communicate between processes, I won't be able to distribute the process to your machine if it tries to use the shared memory to communicate with the process running on my machine.
有一套你需要满足的限制才能使用我们的产品。所以进程间通信就是其中之一，但这真的取决于你进行进程间通信的方式。例如，如果你使用共享内存来在进程之间通信，如果它试图使用共享内存与在我机器上运行的进程通信，我就无法将该进程分发到你的机器上。
So this is something we do not support. But if you're using TCP IP, which usually you won't do for inter-process communication, but if you do, that's supported. That's not a problem because it can work across the network. So it really depends on how you implement process communication. Another thing that we have a lot is a scenario in which you execute multi-process,
所以这是我们不支持的东西。但如果你使用 TCP/IP，通常你不会为了进程间通信而这样做，但如果你这样做，那是支持的。那不是问题，因为它可以在网络上工作。所以这真的取决于你如何实现进程通信。我们拥有的另一个常见场景是，你执行多进程，
which do inter-process communication using shared memory, for example. But it's okay to run all of these kind of processes on a single machine. So you just need to tell us in a way that these processes should run together on a single machine and we'll distribute all of them as a batch to a specific machine. Yeah, that makes sense. So, you know, I guess a lot of people, I would imagine almost everyone listening has built code. Almost everyone listening has, you know, opened up Visual Studio or run GCC or something like that, right? And for most, you know, when I was in college,
它们使用共享内存进行进程间通信，例如。但在一台机器上运行所有这些类型的进程是可以的。所以你只需要以某种方式告诉我们，这些进程应该在一台机器上一起运行，我们将把它们全部作为一个批次分发到特定的机器上。是的，这很有道理。所以，你知道，我猜很多人，我想几乎每个听众都构建过代码。几乎每个听众都，你知道，打开过 Visual Studio 或运行过 GCC 之类的，对吧？对于大多数，你知道，当我在大学时，
most of my projects compiled pretty quickly. So going to just the sort of origin of the company, why do builds take a long time? Why do they need to be parallelized? Why don't builds just finish in three seconds? Yeah, I wish they would. I'm not sure that I would say that again because otherwise I won't have a lot of things to do here. Although, as I said, we are doing today, I think that the industry is going towards testing and not only building.
我的大多数项目编译得相当快。所以回到公司的起源，为什么构建需要很长时间？为什么它们需要被并行化？为什么构建不能在三秒钟内完成？是的，我希望它们能。我不确定我会再说一遍，因为否则我在这里就没有太多事情可做了。虽然，正如我所说，我们今天正在做，我认为行业正在走向测试，而不仅仅是构建。
If you're going, for example, just as a side note, if we're speaking about the trend of continuous integration, continuous delivery, DevOps, so you want to streamline the ability to take your product to deployment every time and have short iterations. I see a trend of companies investing a lot of effort in testing even more than in other areas because if you want to deploy automatically, you need to have a very, very large coverage. Yeah, that makes sense. And nowadays with the Internet, they're constantly pushing out new patches. And so they want to make a new release every week or every month
如果你去，例如，只是作为一个旁注，如果我们谈论持续集成、持续交付、DevOps 的趋势，那么你想要简化每次将你的产品投入部署并进行短迭代的能力。我看到一个趋势，公司在测试上投入了大量精力，甚至比在其他领域投入更多，因为如果你想自动部署，你需要有非常非常大的覆盖率。是的，这很有道理。而且现在有了互联网，他们不断地推出新的补丁。所以他们想每周或每月进行一次新的发布。
or something like that. And every single release needs to be good. Yeah, not only that, we see a trend and that's very popular. And I think the industry is moving towards this direction. And that's the holy grail. But we already see companies doing this holy grail. So every commit that a developer pushes can be automatically deployed into production automatically. And that's amazing
之类的。而且每一个版本都需要是高质量的。是的，不仅如此，我们看到了一个非常流行的趋势。我认为整个行业都在朝着这个方向发展。这就是所谓的“圣杯”。但我们已经看到有公司在实现这个“圣杯”了。所以，开发人员推送的每一个提交都可以自动部署到生产环境中。这太棒了。
because that really gives you the competitive edge. As a CTO, as someone who manages software delivery, I can tell you that a lot of times the developer says, yeah, we finished it one month ago, but unless it's
因为这确实能给你带来竞争优势。作为一名首席技术官，作为一名负责软件交付的人，我可以告诉你，很多时候开发人员会说，是的，我们一个月前就完成了，但除非它
on the users running, you didn't do anything. If it's only on your environment, you actually didn't deploy anything. The trend is towards continuous deployment, which means that once I do something, I'll fix a bug as a developer,
已经在用户那里运行了，否则你什么都没做。如果它只在你的环境中，你实际上什么都没有部署。现在的趋势是持续部署，这意味着一旦我做了什么，比如我作为一个开发人员修复了一个 bug，
I'll push commits, and then I'll have a completely automatic flow that will take my commit into production without me doing any manual thing in the middle. And it will be able to also automatically roll back. But in order to achieve that, you need to have a lot of testing
我会推送提交，然后我就会有一个完全自动化的流程，将我的提交直接部署到生产环境，中间不需要我进行任何手动操作。而且它还能自动回滚。但要实现这一点，你需要进行大量的测试，
because you need to make sure things work correctly in order to be automatic, full automatic. And that's where I see more and more users using Credible to actually accelerate their testing. So that was a side note. But for compilations you're right. If you are doing a very small software, it usually takes a few seconds. It actually also depends on the language you're using. So languages that compile to machine code such as C and C++
因为你需要确保一切运行正常，才能实现全自动化。这就是我看到越来越多的用户使用 IncrediBuild 来加速测试的原因。这是一个题外话。但对于编译来说，你是对的。如果你在开发一个非常小的软件，通常只需要几秒钟。这实际上也取决于你使用的语言。所以，像 C 和 C++ 这样编译成机器码的语言，
will take longer to compile than languages which compile to intermediate language such as C Sharp and Java. So essentially you have, we are working with users that have very, very large code base. I don't want to mention names, but very large software running on your Windows OS,
比像 C# 和 Java 这样编译成中间语言的语言需要更长的编译时间。所以本质上，我们正在与拥有非常、非常庞大代码库的用户合作。我不想提名字，但他们有非常庞大的软件在 Windows 操作系统上运行，
they can have the largest that I'm familiar with working with IncrediBuild has 20 gigs of source code. And I'm speaking only source code. Yeah, that's pretty amazing. That's unbelievable. Yeah, that's one of the, it's a very known product. It's used by a lot of users worldwide. And that's 20 gigs of source code. 20 gigs?
他们拥有的最大代码库我非常熟悉，使用 IncrediBuild 处理的代码量达到了 20GB。我指的仅仅是源代码。是的，这太惊人了。简直难以置信。是的，这是一个非常知名的产品。它被全球许多用户使用。那可是 20GB 的源代码。20GB？
I mean, I'm trying to wrap my head around that. Just sources. Each line is 80 bytes, right? And so, yeah, that's a lot. Yeah, that's a lot. And it takes something like,
我的意思是，我正在努力理解这个概念。仅仅是源代码。每一行是 80 字节，对吧？所以，是的，这确实很多。是的，这确实很多。而且它需要大约，
to compile this software, it takes commercial software, it takes 20 hours to compile it. And you can reduce it to less than an hour. Maybe I'm getting this wrong, and I'm going to get a ton of hate mail, but I just did 20 billion divided by 80. So assuming every line is completely full of code,
编译这个软件，商业软件，需要 20 个小时才能编译完成。而你可以将其缩短到不到一个小时。也许我算错了，我可能会收到一大堆愤怒的邮件，但我只是做了 200 亿除以 80。所以假设每一行都完全写满了代码，
which is a very conservative estimate, you're still looking at 250 million lines of code. Yeah, that's a lot of software having. Yeah, but a lot of it could be auto-generated. Yeah, that's... But you have a lot of software having... Yeah, but a lot of it could be auto-generated code. Yeah, that's true. Yeah, exactly. So that's one of the...
这是一个非常保守的估计，你仍然面对着 2.5 亿行代码。是的，这确实有很多软件。是的，但其中很多可能是自动生成的。是的，那……但你有很多软件……是的，但其中很多可能是自动生成的代码。是的，那是真的。是的，没错。所以这就是其中之一……
You're asking how do we reach this kind of large code. So auto-generated code, using templates, working with third-party libraries that you don't know exactly what's going on there. So this really makes your code very loud. I saw a game recently where they actually had, it was EVE Online, actually has Chrome, the entire Chrome framework in the game so that they can do browsers. So, for example, the help in the game is actually a web browser that renders in the game so that they can do browsers. So, for example, the help in the game is actually a web browser
你问我们是如何达到这种大规模代码量的。所以自动生成的代码、使用模板、使用你并不完全了解内部运作的第三方库。这确实让你的代码变得非常臃肿。我最近看到一个游戏，实际上是《EVE Online》，它在游戏中包含了整个 Chrome 框架，这样他们就可以做浏览器。所以，例如，游戏中的帮助实际上是一个在游戏中渲染的网页浏览器。
that renders in the game. And to make that happen, they have all of Chrome. So I'm pretty sure Chrome is a ton of code. Actually, it's part of our regression. The Chrome project is part of our regression tests. So we want to make sure that we ship products correctly and we have our own tests. The way that we test our product and see that we didn't introduce new bugs into it is to run a lot of these kind of products. We compile Chrome, we compile Qt,
它在游戏中渲染。为了实现这一点，他们包含了整个 Chrome。所以我很确定 Chrome 有海量的代码。实际上，它是我们回归测试的一部分。Chrome 项目是我们回归测试的一部分。所以我们想确保我们正确地发布产品，并且我们有自己的测试。我们测试产品并查看是否引入了新 bug 的方式，就是运行大量这类产品。我们编译 Chrome，我们编译 Qt，
and we compile a lot of large open sources and physics engines, et cetera, in order to see that everything works well. And Chrome really is quite large. It takes a long time to do that, but it's highly powerful. So if you have a lot of resources, you can compile it quite fast, as opposed to if you only have 8 or 16 cores in your machine.
我们编译大量大型开源项目和物理引擎等等，以确保一切运行良好。Chrome 确实非常庞大。编译它需要很长时间，但它功能非常强大。所以如果你有大量的资源，你可以很快地编译它，这与你机器上只有 8 或 16 个核心的情况截然不同。
So yes, that's how you increase your source code. And in today's trend, you have a lot of open sources, you have a lot of open software, etc. So we see a lot of developers, if it's not well-architectured, we see a lot of software having a specific problem and they just find some kind of open source in the net and say, okay, I'll use that to solve my problem. And bam, you have, I don't know, 200,000 lines of code you need to compile. And that grows and grows. Yeah, think also the
所以是的，这就是你增加源代码的方式。在今天的趋势下，你有很多开源项目，你有很多开放软件等等。所以我们看到很多开发人员，如果架构设计得不好，我们看到很多软件有特定的问题，他们只是在网上找到某种开源代码，然后说，好吧，我用那个来解决我的问题。然后砰，你就有，我不知道，20 万行代码需要编译。而且它还在不断增长。是的，也想想
auto generation, you probably have a lot of things that they want baked into the code.
自动生成，你可能有很多东西想要嵌入到代码中。
Even like an icon image and things like that, they'll actually have some
甚至像图标图像之类的东西，他们实际上会有一些
software that converts that into a C file so that it can't be tampered and things
软件将其转换为 C 文件，这样它就无法被篡改，诸如此类。是的，这使得代码库变得非常庞大。我看到的另一件事，当我们看到用户的代码示例时，有时我们会看到人们在他们的包含文件中放置了大量的东西。所以他们把越来越多的东西作为头文件的一部分包含进来，这需要你进行大量的编译才能让它运行起来。所以有很多好的实践，如何编写好的代码，实际上不会加重你的编译时间。坚持并理解开发这种高效软件的一些良好实践是一个很好的习惯。
like that. And yeah, that makes the code base huge. Another thing that I see a lot, and that's something when we see code samples from users, sometimes we see that people are placing huge amounts of stuff in their include files. So they include more and more stuff as part of their headers, which require you to do a lot of compilations in order to get it running. So there are a lot of good practices, how to write a good code that will actually not overload your compilation time. And it's a good practice to adhere and understand that there are some good practices to develop this kind of efficient software.
我们可以现在吐槽一下 Boost 吗？吐槽 Boost？我们不是在谈论保持构建时间短吗？所以我参与了这个项目，这个项目运行得很好，但它是一个副项目，叫做 Eternal Terminal，它只是我们工作场所使用的 SSH 的替代品。其中一件事是，我最终无法像它真正需要的那样投入足够的时间。所以公司实际上雇了一个人，现在全职在做这个。那个人移除了 Boost。我使用 Boost 的唯一原因
Can we rant against Boost now? Against Boost? We're talking about keeping build times low? So I worked on this project, this project that worked, but it was kind of a side project called Eternal Terminal, which is just kind of a replacement for SSH that we're using at the place I work. And one of the things, so I ended up kind of not being able to dedicate as much time to it as it really needs. So the company actually hired somebody who's full-time working on it now. And that person removed Boost. The only thing I was using Boost for
是循环缓冲区和其他一些小东西。是的，编译时间大大加快了。这只是因为我猜它全是需要被分析的头文件库。所以我的意思是，关于 Boost 的笑话是，它总是让构建时间变慢。这不是一个毫无根据的笑话，
was the circular buffer and a couple of other kind of minor things. And yeah, the compilation time sped up enormously. It's just because it's all, I guess, header libraries that are getting analyzed. So I mean, that's the joke about Boost, is that it always makes build times bad. And it's not an unfounded joke,
但它有充分的理由。是的，这是我们在用户中看到的常见问题。我们的许多用户都在使用 Boost，这对我们来说是好事，你知道，因为我们帮助他们编译得更快。你需要考虑的另一件事是，有时你会采用另一个开源项目。例如，你只是想解决某个问题。
but there are good reasons for it. Yeah, that's a common problem that we see with users, with our users. A lot of our users are using Boost, and that's good for us, you know, because we help them compile faster. Another thing you need to take into consideration is the fact that sometimes you take another open source. For example, you just want to solve something.
我不知道为什么。你想要进行一些数学计算或解决一个特定的问题，你看到了一个不错的库，一个不错的开源项目解决了这个问题。而在后台，这个开源项目使用了 Boost，而你甚至不知道这一点。是的。所以这是我们经常看到的情况。如果你正在使用，开发开源的人往往也会依赖其他开源项目，
I don't know why. You want to have some math calculations or a specific problem that you see a nice library, a nice open source that solves that. And in the background, this open source uses Boost, and you don't even know that. Yeah. So that's something we see a lot. If you are using, people that develop open source tend to rely on other open sources as well
以便更快、更稳定地将其推向市场。这很酷。但随后你只是添加了一个开源项目，而在后台，它在不知不觉中为你的代码添加了 10 个以上的开源项目。这就是软件变得越来越大的原因。这是我们越来越多看到的事情之一。而且我预计未来会看到更多，
in order to get it into the market faster and in a more stable manner. That's cool. But then you just add one open source and in the background, it adds 10 more open sources to your code without you knowing that. And that's how software gets bigger. And that's one of the things that we see more and more. And I expect to see even more in the future
因为开源确实是市场的发展方向。你可以看到很多公司，商业公司，正在开放他们的代码成为开源。是的。是的，这就是行业的发展方向。所以我认为我们会看到更多这种情况。是的，我认为这在某种程度上就像游戏，从博弈论的角度来看，
because open source is really where the market is going. You can see a lot of companies, commercial companies, opening up their code to be open source. Yeah. And yeah, that's where the industry is moving. So I think that we'll see more of that. Yeah, I think it's in some sort of like game, from a game theoretic standpoint,
它现在处于某种状态，如果一家公司不打算将其技术开源，这实际上会给在该公司工作的人带来责任，对吧？微软很长一段时间都是这样，他们起诉 Mono 的人，嗯，他们实际上……他们制作了闭源版本的 Java，即 J++，我想 Oracle 起诉了，我不知道，但他们试图把一切都锁死。他们发现很难获得人才，甚至很难让人使用该软件，因为它造成了这种责任。
it's in some kind of well right now where if a company isn't going to open source their technology that actually creates a liability for the people who are working at that company right like microsoft was like this for a long time they were suing the mono people um they were actually uh they made their closed source version of java the j plus plus and i think oracle sued i don't know but they were trying to keep everything locked down. And what they found is that it was just very hard to get talent and even to get people to use the software because it creates this liability.
现在你确实看到微软有点像是最后加入这个行列的人，但他们正在开源更多的技术，现在拥抱 Mono 之类的东西。所以我可以告诉你，从我最近看到的系列报道等来看，微软是当今最大的开源贡献者之一，这……是的，是的，他们开源了，而且他们开源的速度，我认为还有 .NET，他们开源了许多曾经非常封闭的工具。这对他们非常有好处。这对行业、对他们自己以及对采用率都非常有好处。
And now you really see Microsoft kind of being one of the last people to the party there, but open sourcing a lot more of their technology and and now embracing mono and things like that so i i can tell you that uh from recent uh series that i saw etc that microsoft is one of the today's one of the largest contributors to open source which is uh which is yeah yeah and they open source and the speed they open source i think also dot net and they open source many of their tools that once were very close. And it's very good for them. It's doing very good for the industry, for them as well, and for the adoption.
人们现在能够更有效地添加和使用这些东西。这就是一切的发展方向。所以我认为我们会看到正如我所说的越来越多这种情况。是的，我实际上尝试了 Visual Studio Code，这是一个全新的浏览器，他们 fork 了 Atom，这是 GitHub 公司创建的 GitHub 浏览器，Visual Studio Code 非常棒，它是完全开源的，我真的、真的很印象深刻。它有大量的用户。它真的很好。它运行得非常快。
And people now are able to add and work with this more efficiently. And that's where everything is going. So I think that we'll see as i said more and more of that yeah i actually tried the uh visual studio code which is a brand new browser they forked uh adam which is a github browser created by the github company and uh visual studio code is pretty amazing uh it's totally open source and i was was really, really impressed. It has tons of users. It's really good. It works really fast.
他们真的在投入精力使其轻量、快速且跨平台。它支持……我上次看到它时，它支持超过 100 种语言。是的。它真的很酷。这是一个很酷的产品。是的，是的。它太棒了。
They're really investing in making it light and fast and cross-platform, of course. And it supports. The last time I saw it was something like more than 100 languages. Yeah. It's really cool. It's a cool product. Yeah, yeah. It's amazing.
我相信明年你也会在其中看到 IncrediBuild。它真的很酷。这是一个很酷的项目。是的，它太棒了。我相信明年你也会看到 IncrediBuild。所以不仅仅是 Visual Studio。我们有越来越多的商业工具，还有 IDE，所以你可以在 Qt Creator、Visual Studio 中使用它，正如我所说，而且
And you're going to see Incredibil there as well, I believe, next year.'s really cool. It's a cool project. Yeah, it's amazing. And you're going to see IncrediBuilder as well, I believe, next year. So it's not only Visual Studio. We have more and more commercial tools, also IDEs, so you can work with it in Qt Creator, in Visual Studio, as I said, and
你很快也会在 Eclipse 和 CLI 以及其他工具中看到它。所以当你尝试……我猜，在你提到的意义上，哦，你会在这里看到它，你会在这里看到它。所以仍然有一些终端用户需要做的事情，比如带我们了解一下终端用户必须做什么。假设我做了一些进化计算系统，它是我写的一个二进制文件。它创建了一堆进程，每个进程都做一些模拟，然后我收集结果并进行一些分析，对吧？
you're going to see it soon in Eclipse and in CLI and others as well. So when you try to, I guess, in the sense that you're mentioning, oh, you're going to see it here, you're going to see it there. So there's still something that the end user, like kind of walk us through what the end user has to do. Let's say I made some evolutionary computation system, and it's some binary I wrote. It creates a bunch of processes, and each of them does some simulation, and then I collect the results and do some analysis, right?
所以我有了这个 EXE。它在我的机器上完成了所有这些，我想使用 IncrediBuild。我必须做什么？换句话说，支持一个新应用程序需要涉及什么？是的，所以让我们假设你的主进程是 main，
So I have this EXE. It does all of this on my machine, and I want to use IncrediBuild. What do I have to do? In other words, what is involved in getting it to support a new application? Yeah, so let's assume that your main process is main
你的子进程是 sub。主进程执行 100 个子进程。将 IncrediBuild 集成到其中的方法是打开一个 XML 文件，并说 main.exe 空格 allow intercept 等于 true。这告诉 IncrediBuild 这是执行子进程的父进程。然后你换一行，说 sub.exe 空格 allow remote 等于 true，这告诉 IncrediBuild 每次这个主进程执行子进程时，
and your sub-processes are sub. And main process executes 100 sub-processes. So the way to integrate IncrediBuild into that is to open an XML file and to say main.exe space allow intercept equals true. That tells IncrediBuild that this is the parent process that executes sub-processes. And then you have a new line and you say sub.exe space allow remote equals true, which tells IncrediBuild every time that this main process will execute a sub-process,
我希望这个子进程由 IncrediBuild 远程执行。就是这样。这是你需要编辑的唯一配置文件。然后让我们假设你的主命令是 main.exe 100，它告诉你的 main.exe 运行 100 个子进程。你唯一需要做的就是说，ibconsole，这是 IncrediBuild 命令行界面，斜杠 command，并将你的原始命令传递给 IncrediBuild。就是这样。这就是你需要做的所有集成。你的 100 个子进程将由 IncrediBuild 自动分发，
I want this sub-process to be executed remotely by IncrediBuild. And that's it. That's the only configuration file you need to edit. And then let's assume that your main command was main.exe 100, which tells your main.exe to run 100 sub-processes. The only thing you need to do is say, ibconsole, which is the IncrediBuild command line interface, slash command, and pass your original command to IncrediBuild. And that's it. That's all the integration you needed to do. And your 100 sub-processors will be automatically distributed by IncrediBuild,
你所有的输出都将自动同步回你的本地机器。从你的角度来看，这真的就像你的本地笔记本电脑上有 100 个核心一样。就是这样。这只需要两分钟。所以当你说明年 IncrediBuild 将进入 Visual Studio Code 时，例如。那么那将是一个带有专为 Visual Studio Code 设计的 XML 文件的模块。而且……是的，我猜就是那个 XML。哦，而且它在启动二进制文件时必须调用 IncrediBuild 函数。
and all your outputs will be automatically synced back to your local machine. And from your perspective, it's really as though you have 100 cores on your local laptop. That's it. It will take you two minutes. So when you say IncrediBuild is coming to Visual Studio Code, for example. So what that would be is like a module that would come with an XML file that's designed for Visual Studio Code. And and yeah, I guess just that XML. Oh, and also it would have to call the IncrediBuild function when it's launching the binary.
所以它会做这两件事，但你会把它作为一个包提供给 Visual Studio Code。实际上，用户已经在 Visual Studio Code、Eclipse、CLion 等中使用 IncrediBuild 了，因为它们背后本质上都有一个命令行。所以你今天可以使用它，你实际上可以用 IncrediBuild 执行你拥有的任何命令行。所以如果你使用 CLion，例如，一旦你用 CLion 编译你的代码，它就会生成一个 CMake，这是一个构建系统，一个 CMake 命令行。
So it would do those two things, but you would provide that as like a package for Visual Studio Code. Actually, users are already using IncrediBuild, both in Visual Studio Code with Eclipse, with CLion, et cetera, because they all have essentially a command line behind them. So you can use today, you can actually execute any command line that you have with IncrediBuild. So if you're using CLion for example, once you compile your code with CLion it generates a CMake which is a build system, a CMake command line.
你今天就可以简单地获取这个 CMake 命令行并运行它。客户正在这样做。他们只是用 IncrediBuild 运行他们的 CMake 命令行，并加速他们的 CLion 执行。当我提到我们集成到其中时，这意味着我们需要有一个插件和扩展，你可以在 IDE 本身中看到。这并不意味着人们今天不使用它，但这只是一个制作 IncrediBuild 插件的问题，它将包装一切并与 IDE 本身交互。我们还有一个非常、非常酷的可视化，它非常棒，因为它允许你拥有所有这些
You can simply take this CMake command line and run it also today. Customers are doing that. They're just running their CMA command line with IncrediBuild and they accelerate their C-line executions. When I'm saying that we integrate into that, it means that we need to have a plugin and extensions that you see as part of the IDE itself. It doesn't mean that people are not working with it today, but it's just a matter of doing usually a plugin of IncrediBuild that will wrap everything out and will interact with the IDE itself. We also have a very, very cool visualization, which is very, very great because it allows you to have all these
成千上万行的文本输出，由 IncrediBuild 以图形表示形式绘制给你。所以你可以很容易地看到什么在运行，在哪里运行。如果它失败了，你会看到一个红条。如果它失败了，你会看到一个红条。如果它成功了，你会看到一个绿条。你可以看到我们正在使用多少计算能力，你的进程正在处理多少文件等等。
hundreds of thousands of lines of textual output drawn to you by IncrediBuild as a graphical representation. So you can see very easily what's running, where it's running. If it fails, you'll see a red bar. If it fails, you'll see a red bar. If it succeeds, you'll see a green bar. You can see how many computation power we're using, how many file your processes are doing, etc.
一旦你用 IncrediBuild 执行任何操作，你就会开箱即用地获得该功能。所以无论是计算、测试还是其他任何事情。你用 IncrediBuild 做，你就会得到你正在进行的执行的这个非常酷的图形表示。所以在 IncrediBuild 内部的免费版本中，
And once you execute anything with IncrediBuild, you'll have that out of the box. So it's either from computation or testing or anything else. You'll do with IncrediBuild, you'll get this very cool graphical representation of the executions that you're making. So in the free version that Incredibly has inside,
它随 Visual Studio 2017 一起发布，你可以直接运行你的编译，你会以图形方式看到你的编译。你将能够快速分析差距和过载区域，以及你在哪里配置不足你的核心等等。所以当我们这样做时，通常我们想把所有这些图形可视化放在 Visual Studio 中。这是 Visual Studio 的一部分，你会把它看作嵌入在 Visual Studio 内部的一个窗口。
the chips with Visual Studio 2017, you can just run your compilations and you'll see your compilation in a graphical manner. And you'll be able to quickly analyze gaps and overloaded areas and where you are under-provisioning your cores, et cetera. So when we do that, usually we want to put all this graphic visualization in Visual Studio. This part of Visual Studio, you'll see it as a Windows embedded inside Visual Studio.
当我们与另一个 IDE 集成时，我们想保持同样的体验。我们希望你有一个插件，一个扩展，你可以直接用 IncrediBuild 构建，然后 IncrediBuild 可视化不会打开一个单独的窗口，而是在 IDE 内部，所以这就是它有意义的方式。
And when we integrate with another ID, we want to keep the same kind of experience. We want you to have a plugin, an extension that you can just build with IncrediBuild and then the IncrediBuild visualization won't open a separate window but inside the ID so this is kind of how it makes sense
所以你提到了免费增值，如果我是一个靠吃方便面生活的大学生，我只是想把它安装在……你知道，我的整个宿舍，这样我们所有人都可以更快地构建我们的代码……你知道，什么是免费的，然后什么功能……需要专业版？是的，所以……免费版本让你能够以分布式方式使用 IncrediBuild，仅限 5 个代理，每个代理最多 16 个核心，但仅限
so you mentioned freemium so if I'm a college student living on ramen noodles and I just want to install this on you know my whole dorm so that all of us can can build our code faster uh you know what what is the what is free and then what features you know uh costs require the professional bill yeah so uh the free version gives you the ability to use incrediblyiBuild in a distributed manner only for five agents up to 16 core each, but only
一个月。虽然我们有针对学生的特别折扣，但我知道对于学生来说，因为我过去也是学生，所以我知道它是如何运作的。但免费版本中真正终身免费的部分是你能够在本地机器上运行它的能力。
for a month. Although we have special discounts for students, but I know for a student that I was a student in the past as well, so I know how it works. But the actual free-for-life part of the free version is the ability for you to run it on your local machine.
然后你可能会问，好吧，那个非常棒的技术是分发技术。如果我只能在本地机器上运行它，它对我有什么帮助？所以首先，我说的可视化部分是你将能够在免费增值版中终身免费使用它。它真的很酷，它确实有助于查看正在发生的事情，它确实有助于分析你的构建并更清楚地看到错误。
And then you can ask, well, that incredibly great technology is the distribution technology. How would it help me if I can only run it on my local machine? So first, the visualization part that I said is you'll be able to use it for free for life in the freemium edition. And it's really cool and it really helps to see what's going on, and it really helps to analyze your builds and see errors more clearly.
这是一个播客，所以我不能展示任何东西，但它真的很酷。你可以进入我们的网站查看一些画廊。我们专门为我们拥有的另一件事是，我们有一个非常丰富的命令行界面。例如，你可以说在第一个错误时停止，而不是仅仅让你的编译继续，这是 Visual Studio 运行的默认方式。我们在 IncrediBuild 中做的另一件事，它是免费增值版的一部分
And it's a podcast, so I can't show anything, but it's really cool. You can go into our website and see some galleries. And another thing that we have specifically for us, and we have a very rich command line interface. So, for example, you can say stop on first error instead of just letting your compilation continue, which is the default way of Visual Studio to run. And another thing we did in Incredible, and it's free as part of the free room edition
对于 Visual Studio，例如，我们有……这是我没有深入研究的东西，因为我们正在做的事情太多了，我无法深入所有细节。我们刚刚谈到了该技术的主要概念。但对于 Visual Studio，例如，我们有预测执行。所以它允许我们实际上比通常使用的默认方式更好地利用你自己的本地核心。
for Visual Studio, for example, is we have, and that's something I didn't delve into because there are so many things that we are doing, I can't go into all the details. We just spoke about the main concept of the technology. But for Visual Studio, for example, we have predictive execution. So it allows us to actually utilize your own local cores much better than the default way it's being used usually.
所以如果你有一些……是的，所以我们知道你的解决方案中的真正依赖关系是什么，我们知道如何实际上更好地运行它。即使你，例如，如果你定义了一些不需要的依赖关系，我们将能够检测到。有时，例如，如果你有项目 2，而项目 2 依赖于项目 1，那么通常你会看到的方式是
So if you have some, yeah, so we know what's the real dependencies in your solution, and we know how to actually run it better. Even if you, for example, if you define some dependencies that are not needed, we'll be able to detect. Sometimes when, for example, if you have project two, and project two depends on project one, then usually the way that you'll see that
你看到项目 1 的编译在运行，然后是项目 1 的链接，然后是项目 2 的编译，然后是项目 1 的链接，然后是项目 2 的编译，然后是项目 2 的链接。但本质上大多数时候，不是总是，但大多数时候，只有项目 2 的链接部分依赖于项目 1 的链接部分，
is you see the combinations of project one running, and then the link of project one, and then the combinations of project two, and then the link of project 1, and then the compilations of project 2, and then the link of project 2. But essentially most of the times, not always, but most of the time, only the link part of project 2 depends on the link part of project 1,
而不是编译。所以有了 IncrediBuild，我们的预测执行将知道这一点，并将能够并行运行项目 1 和项目 2 的编译，然后是项目 1 的链接和项目 2 的链接，所以我们实际上可以提高你的性能，你的构建时间性能，即使在你的本地基础设施上，不仅仅是在你进行分布式构建时。非常酷。所以这是一个随机的问题，但我似乎记得几年前在 GCC 邮件列表中，
and not the compilations. So with IncrediBuild, our predictive execution will know that, and will be able to run in parallel the compilations of project one and project two and then the link of project one and the link of project two so we can actually increase your performance your build time performance even on your local infrastructure not only when you're doing distributive builds very cool so this is kind of a random question, but I seem to remember on a GCC mailing list a few years back,
有人谈论像多进程链接器或分布式链接器。那存在吗，还是那只是一种幻想？因为我记得链接部分。例如，如果你所有的库都是，比如说，你正在构建的静态库，那么链接部分确实是你在性能方面最头疼的问题。你可以使用 IncrediBuild 来加速链接，或者
someone talking about like a multiprocess link or a distributed linker. Does that exist or is that just kind of a fantasy? Because I remember the linking part. For example, if all your libraries are, let's say, static libraries that you're building, then the linking part is really what's going to kill you in terms of performance. Can you use IncrediBuild to speed up the link, or
Visual Studio 中的链接仍然只在一个进程上？不仅仅是 Visual Studio。我没有听说过可以把你的链接分解成多个进程的东西。是的，我记得看到有人基本上提出了它。但是的，我猜它从来没有真正存在过。
is the link in Visual Studio still only on one process? It's not only Visual Studio. I didn't hear something that can break your linking into multiple processes. Yeah, I remember seeing someone just basically positing it. But yeah, I guess it never actually existed.
是的，我知道这总是来自行业，因为链接是瓶颈，因为它们只能在单个核心上顺序运行。除非你有多个链接，有了 IncrediBuild，例如，一旦我们链接一个特定的项目，我们就可以并行编译以后需要编译的其他项目。所以这是让我们能够……链接将不会成为瓶颈。
Yeah, I know that that's something always coming from the industry because links are bottlenecked because they can only run sequentially on a single core. And unless you have multiple links, with Incredible, for example, once we link a specific project, we can in parallel compile other projects that will need to be compiled later on. So this is something that allows us to, the link will not be a bottleneck.
但仍然，链接在任何地方都是一个主要的瓶颈。微软，例如 Visual Studio 和其他人解决它的方式是尝试最小化延迟，最大化性能并优化主进程本身。所以，例如，在最近的 Visual Studio 中，微软默认引入了一个标志
But still, the link is a major bottleneck everywhere. And the way that Microsoft, for example, Visual Studio and others are addressing it is to try and minimize the latency, to maximize the performance and optimize the main process itself. So, for example, in Visual Studio recently, Microsoft introduced by default a flag
叫做 FastLink，它优化了链接时间。但这就是他们目前解决这个问题的方式。我没有听说过任何可以将链接时间分解成多个进程的东西，但我们真的希望它发生，因为那样 IncrediBuild 将
which is called FastLink which optimizes the link time. But that's the way they address this problem currently. I didn't hear of anything that can break the link time into multiple processes but we really want it to happen because then IncrediBit will
能够将这些多链接进程分发到额外的机器上，甚至会……因为那样 IncrediBuild 将能够将这些多链接进程分发到额外的机器上，并且实际上会进一步增加链接时间，所以一旦这个可用，我将是第一个采用它的人，所以是的，我实际上查了一下，它存在，它叫做 gold，所以它是一个 gold，它可能只适用于 Linux，或者可能不适用，或者可能不适用，但……但是的，如果你使用 gold 链接器，那么它……那么它……它在多个核心中运行，所以是的，潜在地……也许这个 gold 可以与 IncrediBuild 一起工作，尽管它可能……它可能有太多的依赖关系，以至于
be able to distribute these multi-linking processes into additional machines and will actually even happen because then IncrediBit will be able to distribute these multi linking processes into additional machines and will actually even more increase the link time so once this will be available I will be the first to adopt it so yeah I actually I looked it up and it exists it's called gold so it's a gold only it's only for Linux maybe or maybe not or maybe not but uh but yeah if you use the gold linker then it's uh then it uh it runs in multiple cores so yeah potentially uh maybe this gold will work with incredibuild although it might it might have so many dependencies that
在……你知道，文件传输方面可能不值得，文件传输最终可能会成为瓶颈。我听说文件传输可能是一个瓶颈，但在今天的网络中并没有那么多。我知道有用户在 Linux 版的 IncrediBuild 中使用 Gold 和 IncrediBuild，但我从未考虑过这一点。我从未研究过这一点，所以这是我会做的事情。
it might not be worth it in terms of you know of the file transfer might end up being the bottleneck. I heard that the file transfer can be a bottleneck, but not that much with today's networks. I know that there are users working with Gold with IncrediBuild in the Linux edition of IncrediBuild, but I never considered that. I never looked into that, so that's something I would do.
谢谢。当然，是的，它非常酷。是的，我知道有……我见过一些公司，他们把所有东西都构建为静态库，然后他们进行这种巨大的链接，所以是的，它一定是……它可能是那种技术和其他技术的某种组合。那么作为一家公司的 IncrediBuild 怎么样？所以你说这家公司已经存在十多年了。所以它位于哪里？
Thanks. Sure, yeah, it's pretty cool. Yeah, I know there's, I've seen companies where they build everything as a static library, and then they do this enormous link, and so, yeah, it must be, it's probably some combination of that and some other technology. So what about the Incredibuild as sort of a company? So you said that the company's been around for more than a decade. So kind of where is it located?
你们在招聘吗？你们在招聘什么职位？你们为收听节目的大学生提供实习机会吗？诸如此类的事情，比如与公司相关的事情。好的，在那之前关于 Gold Inc. 的一般性说明。
Are you hiring? What kind of positions are you hiring for? Do you do internships for people listening who are college students? That sort of stuff, like company-related stuff. Okay, so just one note before that about Gold Inc. in general.
其中一件事，它在 IncrediBuild 中真的很酷，因为它是一个通用的基础设施。我们实际上很多时候甚至不知道我们的用户在用我们的产品做什么。所以我可以只是……那是真的。
One of the things, and it's really cool and incredible because it's a generic infrastructure. We actually don't even know a lot of times what our users are doing with our product. So I can just... That's true.
是的，是的。这真的很酷，因为我正在与银行交谈，例如，他们可以过来说，听着，我们正在做大量的金融衍生品。或者我可以有一个客户告诉我，他实际上……那是几年前，例如，我有一个非常、非常、非常大的，最大的游戏工作室之一告诉我，听着，我们正在用 IncrediBuild 加速 Maya，这是一个商业产品。
Yeah, yeah. And that's really cool because I'm speaking with the bank, for example, that can come and say, listen, we are doing this huge amount of financial derivatives. Or I can have a customer telling me that he actually... It was a few years ago, for example, I had a very, very, very large, one of the largest game studios telling me, listen, we are accelerating Maya, which is a commercial product with IncrediBuild.
我说，哇，那太酷了。我不知道 IncrediBuild 正在加速 Maya 计算。这与 gold 链接器也有关。我相信我们有用户在使用任何种类的编译器，任何种类的工具，因为我们对你与我们一起运行的进程是不可知的。所以我们实际上不需要对任何种类的进程进行特定的集成。
And I said, wow, that's cool. I didn't know that IncrediBuild is accelerating Maya computations. And that's something related also to the gold linker. I'm sure that we have users that are using any kind of compiler, any kind of tool, because we are agnostic to the processes that you're running with us. So we don't need to actually do a specific integration with any kind of process.
这就是为什么我们有时甚至不知道 IncrediBuild 被用于所有用户。我再举一个例子。我访问了日本的另一家非常大的公司。他们告诉我他们正在进行压力测试。我说，好吧，你是怎么做到的？所以压力测试是你想要给服务器施加压力的地方。所以在过去，为了给服务器施加压力，他们需要即时配置大量的虚拟机，
And that's why we sometimes don't even know for all the users that IncrediBit is used for. I'll just give another example. I visited another very large company in Japan. They told me that they are doing a stress test in Incredibly. And I said, well, how do you do that? So stress test is where you want to stress the server. So in order to stress the server in the past, they needed to provision a lot of virtual machines on the fly,
把进程复制到那里，并确保它们在同一时间针对服务器运行，以便用请求和处理事情等给服务器施加压力。但他们说，有了 IncrediBuild，我们现在只有一个脚本文件，然后每个开发人员都可以运行这个脚本文件，这些
copy the processes there, and make sure that they are running against the server exactly at the same time in order to stress the server with requests and processing things, etc. But they said, with Incredikit, we only have now a script file, and then every developer can run this script file, these
进程将自动分发到许多机器上，它们将连接到服务器。所以这些是我实际上从客户那里学到的用例，而不是来自我们，这非常好，非常酷。是的，这太棒了。这很了不起。所以关于你的问题，我们到处都在招聘。我们正在招聘软件开发人员。如果你正在做内部……如果你是一名内部 C++ 开发人员，你对操作系统内部、Windows 感兴趣。我们正在寻找专业服务人员、QA 实习生。
processes will be automatically distributed to a lot of machines, and they will connect to the server. So these are use cases that I actually learned from customers and not coming from us, which is very nice and very cool. Yeah, that's amazing. It's remarkable. So regarding your question, we are hiring everywhere. We are hiring software developers. If you're doing internal, if you're an internal C++ developer, you are into operating system internals, Windows. We are looking for professional services guys, QA interns.
这取决于你知道怎么做什么。通常当我们与实习生合作时，它是关于部署 IncrediBuild 和用各种开源工具测试 IncrediBuild，并做一些白皮书和基准测试，并尝试将 IncrediBuild 与开源项目集成，因为外面有太多的工具和软件
It depends on what it is that you know how to do. Usually when we are working with interns, it's around deploying IncrediBuild and testing IncrediBuild with a variety of open source tools and doing some white papers and benchmarks and trying to integrate IncrediBuild with open sources because there are so many tools and software out there
正在进行多进程执行。我们想通知市场，听着，我们也可以做到这一点。我们可以做这种压缩、这种编码和这种混淆等等。这些通常是我们与在我们这里工作的实习生一起做的事情。我们位于特拉维夫，但我们也与国外的人合作。
that are doing multi-process execution. And we'd like to notify the market, listen, we can do that as well. We can do this kind of compression, this kind of encoding, and this kind of obfuscation, et cetera. And that's usually the things that we're doing with interns that are working with us. We are located in Tel Aviv, but we are working with people abroad as well.
我们在日本有一个办事处。我们正在与美国合作。所以如果你在其他地方，你想和我们一起工作，你想在我们这里实习，请告诉我们。酷。酷。很高兴知道。那么什么是……告诉我们关于在 IncrediBuild 工作最酷的事情，
We have an office in Japan. We are working with the U.S. So if you're located elsewhere and you want to work with us and you want to intern with us, just let us know. Cool. Cool. Good to know. So what is – tell us the coolest thing about working at IncrediBuild,
比如办公室，或者一些非常独特的东西，比如可能是地点，可能是……是的，我想我实际上可能……但我实际上喜欢我们的客户，因为我正在与最大的客户合作，做当今世界上最酷的产品。它可以是最大的软件，是商业软件，可以是最受欢迎的游戏。我认为最有趣的事情之一是 IncrediBuild 正在工作的生态系统。
like either the office, something kind of really unique, like could be the location it could be yes I think I actually maybe I would eat but I actually like the our customers because I'm working with the largest customers doing the coolest products in the world today it can be the largest software is the commercial commercial software can be the most popular games. And I think that one of the most interesting things is the ecosystem IncrediBuild is working
所以它是游戏和持续集成、公共云和 DevOps 以及 Visual Studio 和其他 IDE 以及金融衍生品。有太多的事情我需要一直学习，因为 IncrediBuild 被用于如此广泛的问题，以至于我将
inside. So it's gaming and continuous integration, public cloud and DevOps and Visual Studio and other IDs and financial derivatives. And there are so many things I need to learn all the time because Incredibility is used in such a large variety of problems that I will
永远无法应对我们工作的整个生态系统。这种持续学习的环境，你知道，与客户和用户在一起，总是学习新东西，物理引擎，你知道其他基础设施，新技术，这是我们总是需要跟上步伐的东西，因为我们被用于这个巨大的行业内部，在这个行业内部几乎做任何事情，所以这就是我认为最酷的事情之一，我在这里永远不会停止学习，这是我真正喜欢做的事情。酷。非常酷。
never be able to cope with the entire ecosystem we are working in. And this environment of continuous learning and, you know, sticking with the customers and users and always learning new stuff, physics engines, you know other infrastructure new technologies this is something we always need to keep up with the pace because we are used inside this enormous industry to do practically anything inside this industry so that's i think one of the coolest things i i never stop learning here and this is something i really love to do. Cool. Very cool.
有道理。你应该有一个挖掘比特币的回归测试。你已经有了解决方案。你可以资助新办公室。我认为我们几年前就需要从那个开始。是的，没错。酷。好吧，非常感谢……我认为几年前就需要从那个开始，然后。是的，是的，没错，酷。好吧，非常感谢你参加节目。这超级棒，所以有一个免费版本，还有一个学生折扣，所以如果你是学生，一定要看看。我认为它会是，你知道，易用性，我认为，是迄今为止最引人注目的部分。我的意思是，你可以，你知道，在你的宿舍或实验室里，
Makes sense. You should have a regression test that mines a Bitcoin. You already have solutions for that. You could finance the new office. We needed to start with that, I think, a few years ago. Yeah, right. Cool. Well, thanks so to start with that, I think, a few years ago, and then. Yeah, yeah, right, cool. Well, thanks so much for being on the show. This is super awesome, and so there's a free version, and there's also a student discount, so if you're a student, definitely check it out. I think it would be, you know, the ease of use is, I think, by far the most compelling part. I mean, you could, you know, in your dorm or in your lab,
你可以把它安装在一堆机器上，看看会发生什么。就像你现在正在开发的任何软件，你可以只是……我的意思是，假设它是多进程的，你可以只是在这个环境中运行它，然后只是……你知道，看看会发生什么有点疯狂，也许它会让你不必……要么等待很多，要么手动并行化它，所以是的
you could install this on a bunch of machines and just kind of see what happens. Like any software you're developing right now, you could just, I mean, assuming it's multi-processed, you could just run it in this environment and just, you know, it's kind of wild just to see what would happen maybe it would save you from having to uh either wait a lot or or or parallelize it all by hand so yeah
你想要尝试并用 IncrediBuild 加速的项目，在你的大学里等等……只需给我们发个便条，我们会提供帮助。哦，是的，实际上考虑到这一点，给我们一些联系方式，所以网站是什么，incredibuild.com 还是你的网站是什么？是的，incredibuild.com，如果你有什么具体想问的或联系我们
project that you want to try and accelerate it within credit build in your in your university or etc uh just uh drop us a note and we will help Oh yeah, actually with that in mind, give us some ways to reach out, so what's the website, incredibuild.com or what's your website? Yeah, incredibuild.com and if you have something specific you'd like to ask or contact us
我认为最好的方式，如果是技术问题，你可以直接发邮件给 support@incredibuild.com，我们会回复你。酷。非常酷。你在 Twitter 或 Facebook 或任何这些平台上吗？到处都是。
I think that the best way, if it's a technical question, you can just email support at incredibuild.com and we'll get back to you. Cool. Very cool. Are you on Twitter or Facebook or any of that? Everywhere.
好的。到处都是。好的。好的。我们会获取 Twitter 账号和 Facebook 以及所有这些，我们会把它和节目笔记一起发布。太棒了。好的。
All right. Everywhere. Okay. Okay. We'll get the Twitter handle and Facebook and all of that and we'll post it with the show notes. Great. Okay.
酷。非常感谢你的时间，是的，如果任何人有任何问题……是的，查看节目笔记，我们会为你提供联系 Dory 的方式，你可以……给他们发一封邮件 support@incredibuild.com。太棒了，非常感谢你们，这很有趣。片头音乐是 Binar Pilot 的 Axo。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，重新混合、改编作品，
Cool. Thank you so much, much dory for your time and uh yeah if anyone has any questions uh yeah check out the show notes we'll put away for you to get in touch with dory and you can uh shoot them an email support that incredible.com great thanks a lot guys it was great fun the intro music is axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work,
太棒了。非常感谢Dory抽出时间，如果大家有任何问题，请查看节目说明，我们会提供联系Dory的方式，你们可以发送电子邮件至support@incredible.com。非常感谢大家，这真的很有趣。片头音乐是Binar Pilot的《Axo》。Programming Throwdown采用知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可协议发布。您可以自由分享、复制、分发、传播本作品，以及重混和改编本作品。
but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但你必须注明我和帕特里克的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。